bonjour et bienvenue de nouveau sur des
gones altéré pour ce jour numéro deux
rondes de numéro 2 à saint quentin 50 en
2015 championnat de france avec un des
grands maîtres les plus connus en france
peut-être aussi un des des plus
chaleureux un des plus chaleureux un
grand maître en plus ce qui est dans sa
région en tout cas proche de sa région
c'est jean-marc degraeve ça des
remarques
oui bonjour bonne journée aujourd'hui
tout va bien voilà ce que je suis ici
déjà c'est bon signe
alors c'est un peu d'argent mais oui
c'est un peu ma région fut un moment je
suis originaire de deux villes
enfin tourcoing exactement mais proche
de lille contre on met un soin on va
dire 150 kilomètres donc c'est vraiment
je sais pas trop quoi alors jean marc tu
m'as dit alors déjà cette ronde
aujourd'hui elle est vraiment spécial
parce que montage ou un joueur super
qu'on aime beaucoup
bien sûr aussi mais qui est un joueur
qui est un peu la bête noire c'est
romain edouard est qui
on va le voir on met à fournit aussi une
belle partie et toi aussi
mais avant ça territoire temps des bons
voilà j'ai pas je suis pas toujours
aussi un peu paumé il joue pas trouvé là
ça tout de suite et donc j'étais très
stressé dans la voiture et j'ai pas vu
un petit sens interdit que j'ai donc
emprunté et malheureusement il y avait
bien sûr une voiture de flics à ce
moment là comme d'habitude qui m'a
arrêté mais c'est a bien commencé reste
que des flics était super sympa
ils m'ont dit ok où il n'avait pas vu
vous à longchamp pas de france déchets
qu'ils ont vu que j'étais super stressé
ils m'ont emmené tranquillement je suis
la voiture est montée jusqu'au aller
jusqu'à la salle de jeux
à noter n'a pas eu besoin de préciser
que c'était grand maître d'échecs et non
non non non j'ai pas préciser j'ai juste
dit que je ne chante pas de france
d'échecs watrous palais des sports
est ce qu'il faut en tirer comme
conclusion moi c'est la question que je
me pose c'est que si on joue champlain
de france échec on a droit de prendre un
sens interdit
je pense pas je vais pas j'ai pas le
recommencer demain
mais bon c'est un bon si je crois que
c'est un bon quand je suis arrivé je me
suis dit voilà c'est une fournée de
chance joue ma bête noire et gicquel et
j'ai eu de la chance aujourd'hui déjà
donc voila c'était une bonne journée
voilà ça s'est bien déroulé
super journée alors voir cette partie
maintenant bien sûr donc alors on a vu
effectivement que le roumain avait joué
son coup et que bessat en attendait la
réponse puisque horta parti était un peu
la partie vedette de la journée parce
que celle sur laquelle on avait mis une
autre nouvelle interface utilisateur
puis son ami webcam sur la partie alors
donc au niveau donc romain a joué avec
des quatre avec des cathos il peut jouer
qu'à trop signale donc pour se préparer
mais j'ai surtout regardé des 4 donc bon
je jouais reste indienne comme donc
cavalier fille célia 6 c4 c4 g6 la
romagne que jouer deux variantes années
passées il m'a battu avec kalyev 3g 3g 2
donc j'étais plutôt préparé sur g3
faisait d'eux alors à noter à
interrompre leur à peu et tiens puisque
tu parlais de sa de l'année passée
tulette le connaît il est sûre tu vas
jouer beaucoup de parties avec lui et tu
es un score catastrophique jeu j'ai en
fait j'ai joué trois fois et trois fois
c'était les deux dernières fois c'était
des positions où j'étais sale et s'est
étendue et j'ai perdu en fait j'ai zéro
sur trois donc aujourd'hui ça fait un
sur quatre voilà c'était vraiment
aujourd'hui j'ai 0 % contre 20 en tout
cas au début de la partie on en est là
et tient à 0 sur 3 a donc t'es pas
rassuré quand même hein voilà je suis
pas rassuré mais j'ai rien à perdre non
plus je les noirs je compte roma qui est
ma bête noire l'expérience et j'ai gagné
voilà j'ai fait pas non plus
catastrophique si je perdais quest ix je
ne suis pas mis une pression
supplémentaire j'ai plus du bonus si je
fais quelque chose eh oui donc dire tu
as déjà ici très bien démarré ce
national avec une aussi belle victoire
donc c'est quand même bien donc ici donc
il m'a joué l'autre début je m'attendais
aussi donc avalisé ces 3 3 foucher de
cette palestinienne pas de comparaître
devant une faille non pas chez morel
maroger cette enquête a eu quatre des
six cf 3 il décide alors f3 donc ça
c'est la variante la fameuse samia ghali
cheval très solide très solide car
pauvre utiliser beaucoup un moment donc
très solide et non il a joué face à face
au moc c'est dur de jouer les noirs
l'autre dit johanne gauthier aussi je
voudrais je voulais système changeant
entre michou et labatut kasparov
j'ai moi aussi d'ailleurs ce condiment
maintien simultanée là dessus elle m'a
dit 'il m'a dit audible sentheim avis et
toi je vais te soigner je vais rester à
lille donc chez toi et longtemps c'était
entendre ça et les musulmans appellent
petit rock petit rock food faut 3 voilà
développement normal des pièces
or le lait blanc développe en pleurant
parce que comme vous jouez de 3,6 à
l'afp c'est très solide mais ça pose un
problème en ces cavaliers il ya plus sa
case naturel ces cinq alors c'est un
sacrifice de pions avec parce que quand
on prend on peut faire comprendre qui
est théorique très connus théoriques et
les noirs après vont jouer sur la
diagonale g7 du fou g7 bedo qui va
s'ouvrir donc sur cette grande diagonale
et de fait que le fouet fin que le quart
eli gien ont du mal à se développer
donc en fait prendre de pioncer
si on donne beaucoup assez de
compensation pour les noirs beaucoup de
jeux comme tout jeu notamment grâce à
l'ouverture de ses 30 bougies est bonne
d'accord donc il n'a pas plu il a pas
pris donc c'est des cinq noms qui
avaient lieu deux cahiers de d'abord
qu'à eux deux qui surprotègent des cas
tout ce qui suit en vo tlj de cathy va
le prendre des claques à claude terrail
aux petits pros venus de ce coup là bien
sûr c'est que ça bouge le sou le fou
pour l'instant pour l'instant mais ça va
pas durer qu'elle sait si ce bon j'ai
quatre espaces pas de problème donc tu
augmente la pression sur di maria et a
pas peur de te faire chasser
voilà alors là un bon dessin qu'il a le
grand coup théoriquement ces cavaliers
se sentent eux 5
parce que si on se fait attaquer on peut
soit allergique à toute attaque ce
gâteau c'est vrai et on atteint là
regard très bon il moi j'ai pas chose
j'ai pas voulu rentrer dans la grande
tour y en a des prix voire laissa alors
moi je vais préparer ça donc j'ai joué
car il ya cinq-six un coût moins joué
mais qui est tout à fait jouable
voilà mes dix qui peut surprendre
l'équipe réserve qui comme ça il est
moins préparés qu'en tout à fait donc du
coup là d'accord hélas alors donc là je
l'attaqué du plan c'est qu'un problème
sur ces camions qui choisit et justement
de découvrir voilà danger et il sait qu
alger 3 on peut aussi sans doute jouer
pourrait bien rallier g3 on va souvent
aux 9,5 ou dans bourgeoise qu'attache 5
pourront aussi pensé à attaquer voilà
c'est parti contrôle
ici cette case donc vous jouez h45 qui
le cas des moules en coin attaqué lors
on voit la preuve qu'il est donc surtout
là on a défendu ses quatre c'est quand
même assez important on va pas donner un
pion gratuit la suisse est donc à 6
alors remis des dons si bien sûr je vais
b5
la grande idée celle ci joue dam des
deux maintenant voilà que j'ai doublé
cinq ans regarde oui comme des thèmes
des deux c'est ça l'idée des cinq ans
mais l'on prend puis on prend et je
menace kelly b 3 c'est ça le cavalier
parce que ça tacle à tort et on peut pas
prendre puisque attention gala tour à 8
qui la résine et de la variante sais que
je peux jouer b5 magnifique et ça suffit
ça tape si la dame c'est une fourchette
en fait oui c'est une fourchette et même
lorsqu'il peut par contre en plus
inquiet il s'est pas que le danger du
jeu située à la qualité ça n'est plus
que du riz huile non merci papa b5 ou
l'embêter
et bien qu en fait voilà c'est l'idée de
la variante section dam des deux je peux
jouer des cinq dons qu'elle joue pas
d'âme des deux noms qui jouent foulées
d'olt il veut plutôt faux de tranquille
ici pour ça qu'on se doit d'amener
d'accord entre 6 alors aussi alors ça
c'est on avait on a pu analyser un tout
petit peu c'est alors c'est bien sûr
c'est un coup classique on veut attaquer
le centre qui est quand même fort et on
essaie de faire un petit tour et puis en
conjonction avec celle qu'on peut faire
éloigner les pions et du coup c'est
d'ouvrir le centre couvrir mon centre
d'accord donc 6 très bien petit rock
lamont tirs au but quand même il ya main
mais je prends j'en profite que quand il
prend son peugeot de 8,5 alors tu prends
tout de suite au lieu de jouer des
scènes tout de suite ma b 5 me dans le
groupe b 5 léger plus de dialogue étroit
il ya plus de cavaliers detroit mais est
ce que on pouvait pas espérer n'ont même
pas on peut être pas espérer affaiblir
le sang boyer mais simple moi c'est
quand même tu veux pas donner mon accord
de ça pour être un sacrifice position
on a cinq qui n'est pas bien placé quand
même avec le cas les insectes et parce
qu'au début quand tu disais je peux
donner l'option c5
c'est un maïs et là il est tout
développer maintenant alors c'est dans
l'âme et développerez comprennent donc
ça marche moins d'abandons bolide u7
canton de saint-lys quand même c'est
prendre ces francs et illustre et b5
alors ça ce qui est bien parce que tu as
beaucoup d'espacé les dames là on sent
que ses pions ont pris l'espace et de
l'air pour les noirs ils sont
majoritaires en trois points contre 2 et
peuvent gêner les cavaliers c3 tu peux
aussi on engageait des c4 ou le câble et
pourrait revenir en sécurité ventura il
ya beaucoup d'idées na kwa dam des deux
dames ghetto ça je l'avais un spot
s'alourdit l'abbé samain kdf 17
donc ça je savais qu'il fallait jouer ça
je l'avais c'était le coup de leur dis
enfin bon j'avais préparé ça ce matin
d'accord donc pour l'instant j'étais
dans ma prépa j'ai 5 c'était dans un
prétoire alors qu'à l'est qui a dit
c'est intéressant parce que vivant ça
libère la pression fait la faute
l'idée midget d'amd dos et d'échanger
mon super fou de cases noires ont 20 h
10 oui bien sûr donc quand il vous faut
acheter je vous fous des quatre échecs
maintenant oui et après je bouge m'a
tout comme ça j'ai gardé mes après tours
voilà là et je garde donc il faut à tout
prix que je conserve
mon foot 15 noir protéger mon droit car
un fou à la fois de protection et de
monde hier les attaques du sandzak super
bien je voulais me garder d'accord très
bien aimé la jaune rouge et 5 voilà côté
là par contre tu ne n'avais pas prévu
ouais voilà par contre le jeu n'est
peut-être pas peut-être d'un v6 est
mieux que dams et moi j'ai joué comme
ccmc 7
il ya parti tu te dis que là peut-être
je n'aime pas peut-être d'un v6 et aime
bien cette ambiance d'accord avoir bon
jeu il faut du diénat liseré ça après la
partie le problème de l'oeuf ou g5 sinon
c'est comme les blancs ce retrait
content que les noirs jouant ici ça
bouge totalement ce point là d'accord
donc il faut pas ne faut faire
comprendre ça quand on joue quand on
débute etc
c'est pas parce que l'adversaire va vous
chasser une pièce donc donc comme si c
est quand même alors comme ce fait comme
ses sept
donc tu estimes un peu quand même un peu
faiblard au vu de son mari mais voilà
d'accord fois çi sommes bien flashy donc
ce fameux échange de leur église de
défense fou de quatre échecs jeu donc je
m'interroge
l'idée un jour - châteauroux 8 et
maintenant tours 8 voilà le coup
justement qui m'embête cb4 comme dans la
paroisse est alors complètement
inattendu
maintenant j avais confié je pensais pas
que c'était aussi fort c'est une
occasion se dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ce trou puisque on donne le pion
mais en fait on ne donne pas parce que
concurrents il ya quelques épreuves les
cinq dallas on regarde si l'on prend qui
on prend des combles et 5 ont fait pas
non pas on préfère dame prend fou il ya
d'impro cavani mais parce que dans le
grand fond se disent à mon asthme attend
plus les rebonds mais non dame prend
cavaliers on va le faire pour montrer
aux spectateurs d'un prince ou dans ce
cas là de balles travaillées et
évidemment il ya pas mal puisque la dame
contrôlent la quasi les est donc en fait
presque sa force presque le change des
dames et puis les noirs sont tranquilles
en trois pions entre maintenant plus
c'est plus que tranquille sommes
contents mais bon nous nous basons donc
mais c'est inattendu ce voyage c'est
vrai que c'est surprenant quand on le
voit en direct comme ça donc surpris on
prend b4 alors qu'elle valait prendre du
sens et là simplement cavale et prendre
des 5
c'est une variante et l'on prend
simplement donc ça attaque
la dame on se dit que là aussi ça
attaque le fou donc on n'a pas trop
chaud pour reprendre et maintenant on
prend voilà le fou ce qui n'est pas la
même
maintenant qu'on a pris un pion au
passage ils font des cinq reprises mais
non j'ai en plus ceux qui ont des seins
catastrophe le pire mais s'inquiète un
prix du chez-nous leurs cases noires pas
la même il faut que je vous donne ses
trois quand même et avait changé je
prendrais sont échangés on prend en
compte des 5es et les blancs sont
nettement mieux donc sur b4 sauf de cake
je veux qu'elle sait quand tu vas jouer
peut-être le seul coup on qui doit être
donc cavalier ses quatre fantastiques
sinon ça perd du temps dans les tours de
quatre enfants l'homme et 4e breathe me
souhaitant prise on n'a pas trop le
choix il faut prendre comprend et puis
on prend soin d'eux prend 1 et comme un
pion prince est certes bon alors là
attention parce que je vous en prie si
on prend avec le fou tu enlèves le vrai
de la diagonale qui compte assez simples
missiles fait un peu peur voilà donc ça
fait un peu peur l'affaiblissement du
roi
il peut y avoir des menaces oui mais en
plus on va très vite sa cavale il peut
venir qu'avec tout de suite gagné on va
voir ses idées après justement donc la
donne en france et 5 seulement où il
faut garder le contrôle sont fait fort
garde surtout le fou sur cette diagonale
de défense alors là il mazout qui avait
dit à cote et j'étais content
l'affluence pas que ça serait d'accord
il y avait mieux tu parles je suis
tranquille cavaliers go2 tout ça ouais
d'accord c'est ce qui m'embêtait le plus
fou fou on va dire il faut bouger il
faut fois de suite par exemple ou
ensuite parce qu'on va pas l'échangé est
fou et roi des fous des quatre attaques
la dame dans le top-15 les fous du cac à
oui ça je ne mets pas du tout ah ben oui
parce que cette femme fut un lien à
médis joueur d'instinct yanhel pas c'est
le fan de foot de bouffe ed oui il ne
veut pas le donner mais je vais regarder
qui avait 200 qui m'a pris un moment il
va même jouer f4
ils ont échangé le fou et f5 et c'est le
roi devient faible et le souss éviter
mauvais génie pions c4 idiot mais non
enfin car je n'aimais pas du tout cette
position d'accord je préférais la partie
comment je perds un pion mais j'ai un
peu d'activité tandis que les non je
pense qu'il y avait eu deux plus forts
et plus fort donc au lieu de quoi il a
fait qualiac avril à le kit à soulager
quoi dire et là on se dit bon on damas
est la dame madame un seuil qui va jouer
autour des 1
il va jouer autour d un tacle fou il
doit revenir il faut outreau à préparer
et après encore à de fou qui a tapé
c'est la même oui c'est lorsqu'il madame
n'a pas de cause on peut concerner des
charreaux lyonnais n'ont donc je joue
ces trois là beaucoup la carrière qu'il
fallait avoir eu ça fait quand même une
première sauvegarde
ces trois tacles adam et oui donc en cas
d'échangé chanter content parce que
disons la faiblesse l'année plus il n'y
a plus beaucoup plus disons que si je
rentre en finale la paire de fou venir
très forte
et oui parce qu'on n'avait qu'un point
de moins je le cavalier g3 sera tout le
temps hors jeu mais moins est ce que il
y aura plus de l'appui de la tête de
matt et avec ma paire de vous même avec
un ton moulin je crains vraiment rien
quoi garde-fous les tours active
agressif et qu'ils prennent 7 5
si on prend 10 2 qu'il fallait prendre
17 vous prendre un mille euros prend le
soin d'en jacca tour nathalie tourné un
long des ces lotos qui va donc voilà qui
peut même pas jouer ce train c'est dur
du coup c'est difficile
oui du coup c'est d'accord donc ici car
il ya quatre ans et trois hommes trois
dames chez eux donc c'est une soit il
avait prévu donc dame ces deux donc là
je savais que j'allais perdre un point
avec la paire de fou j'espérais avoir
ont un peu de jeu est d'ailleurs j'ai
des joueurs même ceux quatre hommes c4
tranquille donc bien puisque la dame
était attaquée il faut oublier donc
maintenant ses quatre tours assez bien
il va prendre ton impression au maximum
ici sur le pion elle est toute la vallée
l'aide à mortain mais il faut que
j'active et le tessin donc le fou j'ai
décidé d'aller le maître en a six comme
ça mes tours vont jouer je vous ai
superbe diagonale quoi oui alors je vois
une belle diagonale parce qu'en plus tu
bois un petit tour derrière avec la dame
joue attendant alain et puis en plus on
voit vite que la case d3 notamment les
3l 4 voilà que le cavalier qui peut
arriver
cavalli qui peut arriver c'est
intéressant donc on se dit les prairies
de jouer le tour c'est 8 pour clouer
aussi un éventuel manque mais un peu
patraque raciste qui est un pion voilà
alors parce qu'ils font qu'augmenter
alors ben j'ai pensé à une poussée il
fallait pousser le canada mais c'est ça
parce qu'il faut voir le plan et après
fossiles il faut donc pousser les pions
voilà l'idée dû pousser les pions s'est
pas décidé d'aller faire dame ici
l'emmener
de développer son fonds à six et ils
prendre les colonies voilà enfin est
donc activé ses pièces voilà le genre de
coups qu'il faut qu'il faut voir quand
on est con voit pas quand on est pas
encore le remettre bien sûr parce que
c'est un couple qui apparemment ne fait
rien et en fait il ya ce coup c'est
magnifique ou de développement de fou
derrière avec cette belle case d3 cette
tour qui traîne derrière tout ça change
tout j'ai 36 3 magique et maintenant
fouet celle là on donne toujours pas
faut jamais donner ce fou et là
attention donc la tour est un maillon
emprise faut corriger la tension et la
dame des 2% lever 2 pour donner un
visage un jour d'un tour dames et aussi
voir le case noire bien sûr le rock
et oui on va pouvoir voir dans la partie
à venir baisse d'impôts titiller le rock
ils menacent aussi cavalier bessin qui
en fait oui oui car ils ont l'intention
oui parce que la torah taxe un point de
vue un peu tout à l'heure déjà mais si
la dame prend prendre le fou mais comme
on est très faible sur cases noires
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle cette fois
une bonne nouvelle c'est pour ça que je
dois bouger mon fou de caisses noires
pour empêcher qu'ils disent qu'ils nous
jouent soit chute et donc voilà où on en
est dans sa passage un transport la
suite voilà
hélas le fou est sorti donc évident que
les 5 en attaque plus le fouille a pas
de problème donc tous rêvent d un il
enlève là on enlève aussi la tour ici
mais la balle on se dit quand même ce
coup bon c'est un bon coup puisqu'on a
eu la tour du du fou mais elle n'est pas
très active en effet rien mais bon il
fallait il faut qu'ils enlèvent faut la
revoir
les problèmes il ne peut pas non plus
jouer beaucoup de coups comme voilà il
n'a pas quantité de coups non plus et là
je cavaliers donc l'adresse des trois c4
ça c'est magnifique aussi parce que
voilà on vise la case d3 et c'est ce
qu'on avait dit avec ce fou ce petit
coup à cinq avaient l'air de rien qui
donne à cazaux dans la case d3 et là on
voit que c'est utile parce qu on a une
tour qui va être attaqué et en plus on a
toujours cette tentation de vouloir
faire un échec en f2 oui et c'est
toujours dangereux mais il a très bien
joué parce que bon j'ai peut-être mal
défendu mais parce que pour lui c'est
dur maintenant oui quand je jouais
qu'elle était trois tours c'est 8
oui la sphère cavalli j'ai trop et
qu'idiot voilà j'ai toutes mes pièces de
bien placé voilà oui les cases noires
sont faibles puisque finalement parce
qu'ils contrôlent bien les classements
je n'ai pas les classements donc au
centre
j'ai toutes les vieilles bien passé il
ya deux bateaux rapides qui passe se fit
jouer pour ces huit comme ça autour des
chaque salle est très rare et très vite
on a eu deux très bons cours alors il
fait celui là où est celui là celui là
ils attaquent la dernière attaque donc
ici qu'a lieu la dame est attaqué
peut-être que là j'ai pas joué demi
parce que je vais des maquettes
bon faut voir la partie d'un beckett est
intéressante d'un beckett qui propose un
échange
donc il ya les grands jeux y aura le
pion à 12 la torah 8 sera bien placé oui
parce qu'après prise la tour attaque le
plan à deux donc c'était peut-être il
changer les dames je crois que ça en ma
faveur
en fait parce que j'ai pu il ya plus d
attaques
sur le droit perdra une trente ans il
veut pas l'échangé perdra un temps où ce
drame soit pas jouer avec 10 3 oui à
calais des trois guerres qui attaquent
la tour et puis il ya toujours que
famille un échec en hd qui se réclament
du cac et amy dam des 4 as l'air très
intéressant tout à fait demain quatre
dames à 4 des témoins content disons
qu'au début non mais comme à sacrifier
la qualité
alors je vais pas penser qu'ils
massacrent pourquoi cela plutôt qu'en
des classico l'idée tu voulais leur
mondial que je joue aux quilles
d'étroites sont que j'allais attaquer
faire pression sur soi tour d un mail à
sales yamanaka tu je vais attaquer à
deux aussi la dame ne peux pas trop
bouger
donc voilà ma gamme et active d'abord en
fait je voyais pas trop ce qu'il faisait
en fait oui mais ce qu'il a fait dans la
partie voilà oui j'ai pas tout bien
calculé coin tout à fait d'accord qui
cueille des cats et carré des quatre
clics et détroit alors la magnifique ce
coup on est mais dans une très bonne
qualité c'est donc en est un c'est
complètement inattendu lawzi d'éclat
traiter un coup surprenant est alors
celui là parce que le problème c'est
qu'on voit pas comme ça à l'image voir
la dame atteinte localisés sur 1000 et
défendu deux fois bon mais le foot ap /
ce cavalier donc si on joue t elle et
detroit avec toujours cette idée que le
fou contrôle des trois attaques la tour
ce qu'elle est il est mort oui donc
positif six coups ce qu'il fait là donc
tu joues que les détroits je joue
qu'elle ait des trous à pourvoir
non mais je veux pas tout calcul est
donc là le ce d'ici joue l'atout rippert
une pièce ne s'est pas l'idée ça doit
être ça me dis donc il joue quel essai
cicae ces six jeunes occupantes ou alors
la grande parce que sinon on n'a rien
parce que la balle est énorme ici et on
va pas il faut prendre tout prendre et
là on se dit est en fait ils commencent
à avoir un deux trois pièces pas loin du
rang à quoi parce que ce cavalier
empêche le roi de bâtiments mais toi ne
joue pas des tours de joubaïl bloc on
peut pas jouer les 8es on s'évite bien
on tape dessus est donc évident aussi
ses qualités comme j'avais calculé alors
hommage écrivait plusieurs autres 8 mai
soit au début on pense prendre
lecavalier 6 il jouait sous 17 vous
baissez être pressé de l'éliminer cette
bête la foulée sept tours seuls huit
mois là bas c'est un peu l'idée donc
mais surtout 17 l'idée c'est bon moi
j'ai joué tous ses goûts ses huit mois
la mémé surface
cette annonce intervient oui bon
cavalier f5 et si tu avais vu ça des
cavaliers qui a l'air très très fort
alors le problème c'est que ça menace
matt ici échec tout reprend le deuxième
cas vallée prend et seimat le roi ne
peut plus bouger
c'est un joli match d'ailleurs donc t'as
pas envie de te faire planter un joli
matt bon jeu et on se dit tu peux
prendre ces six voilà je peux prendre si
ses pions prend et la scala est oui
alors là si vous avez regardé mais ça ça
fait peur parce qu'on a un pion passé
soutenu par une toulon et le problème
c'est que sur notre site
pour ces huit pour essayer de gratter ce
pion ben oui mais il ya des six qui
tombe comme ils l'avaient appréhendé six
donc je ne peux pas jouer autant ce 8
j'avais regardé donc fou au saint-siège
aux menaces
maintenant le cavalier fou aux cinq
variantes
donc je menace que québec a maintenant
menace de prendre parce qu'il n'ya plus
d'âme j'ai cinq échecs avec un quasi
match parce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est
dans cette position
si on prend les surveiller et adam g
saint gall matt voit la main voilà donc
là maintenant je menace de prendre
ils sont obligés de cinq échecs crois
juste mais le problème c'est sûr qu'elle
prend des six c'est mauvais je prend
carrément qu'il n'y a pas de l'impro
tour des huitièmes est du coup bas monde
est d'accord donc donc en fait c'était
mérité mais je n'y crois pas qu'ils
frappent en d6 d'accord qui joue
cavalier de trois jours et dans ce
cas-là cas il ya trois jours et un parce
qu'on a toujours dans le brésil italie
serait ce que j'ai regardé pour 3g pajot
fondé cette cavale trois subit depuis
des cinq essais s'être il va venir là
avec mon cavalier norme est un pion c7
est un pion à ses 7
et là tu es complètement vis et je suis
les cases noires le cahier mon dessin
qui va toujours menacé des choses il ya
des attaques sur le roi tu pourrais
faire et des f4 a finalement su bien
faire si je voulais que je veux que ça
d'accord
voilà pourquoi on ne peut pas jouer
pourquoi j'ai joué au foot c'est vite
sous scellés dans mon concours en pas
faux baiser d'accord deux sets à rien de
menace tout ça va bien 5 tout le temps
donc vous ces huit pour empêcher qu'il y
ait cinq sur calypso
je vous prends 5 et voilà tu veux
prendre des fous et non plus parce que
les pions samat et au ski au début et
pas évident on se dit qu'est ce que
vient faire le plein il était bien la
finale mais c'est vrai qu'ils tapaient
dessus du vide et que l'on a un peu
défendent leurs droits en fait défendre
le roi et surtout le casting est pas
pour venir en 17
c'est surtout pour viser ce à quoi mais
ça intercepte l'action des tours oui bon
après je joue sous 17,6 ferrer s'il fait
un an quand même fait des ailes c'est
trop évident et les vidéos mais quand
même empêché kevin f5 pour l'instant
d'accord très bien qu'il ait dans
l'écriture et la dame et 4 alors à noter
que il semblerait que ici dans cette
position il y avait un coût qui était
quand même étonnant et fort qu'elle
voyage 5 qu'est l'art de rien c'est un
peu la même idée que la partie mais
c'était plus précis que 2004 d'abord en
bon je te le pass je veux pas le leur
mais d'un f4 lescott qui est quand même
fort un 10 qui effectivement bombay est
pourquoi l adam eve gabon d'abord pour
l'attack des six mois on a un oeil sur
m6 donc parce qu'on veut jouer un échec
distance de 600 prend après font prendre
en france et matt mladin muscade d'abord
et la jolie différence oui dames 1 3
damas 3 bon je défends des six défendez
6 et et oui oui parce que même si c'est
défendu deux fois à la fin d'une
variante on prend la tour qui défend le
made du couloir payer ses bottes du
couloir à la fête qui est pénible c'est
toujours toujours ça donc le coût à
double à double idée coadout des pantins
rupture et le h5 et là ça s'est déjà vu
alors qu'avec sa menace le roi est quand
même voilà on sent que le roi et clichés
comme on disait dans le sud donc calé
six échecs pas de casque pour le roi il
faut prendre d'altran est fou et d'amis
avait pas empêché le matin j'ai cette
voie là c'est les noirs joui après ils
sont matin voilà donc ça fait peur
j'étais fou contrôler la toile c'est
très important puisqu'il n'y aura pas
besoin d'en prendre pour matt puisque
toujours le fou justement il faudra
donner la dame en fête est donc là mais
comme en défense alors là voilà bon mais
au début mais j'ai qu'un peu de français
parce que dmb 2 par exemple
au début quand plaisir mais j'ai joué
dans les deux sur corner h 30 sauf le
viage scène qu'on se dit un mais deux
dames b2 enfin c'est pas donc d'un b dom
et il a demandé six wickets à qui
protège la menthe et raciste d'apartheid
à prendre s'il ya même eu cinq fois d'un
produit 6 j'aimais bien madame précise
aussi franches sont et 2008 et c'était
une ligne de vie en train d'amérique
ça aurait fait mal quand même dans les
scènes étaient chers le fou control la
case dans des obligés de prendre de la
tour et regardez où le fameux les tout
faire de problèmes surtout c'est plus
qu'une sortir assez inattendu parce que
le fait rarement sur la casa gémit-il
il est très beau donc tu l'avais lu ça
qui est bouché les grands maîtres ceux
qui voient ils essaient d comme disait
fischer d'ailleurs il évite les belles
variante ça leur plaît pas surtout comme
ces contrôles quand ces produits ça va
encore donc oui ça c'est complètement
dingue vidéo est impossible donc
d'amener n'était possible
donc j'ai joué cinq sur le coup alors ça
c'est un joli coup de défense quand même
parce qu'on voit la scène l'idée c'est
que évidemment on enlève le contrôle de
la case et fils à la dame voila voila tu
as vraiment inaperçu si ça marche qu'on
prend si jamais prendre le 5e jeu la
colonne qui s'ouvre avec des maths et
van klaveren couloir le fameux c'est à
dire que là on se dit mais on comprend
mieux le coup d'envoi 3 parce que
effectivement si on commence à ouvrir sa
plus tard si des concepts dans ma bouche
d'un grand tour et cher s'apprend et
donc le match donc ça m'intéressait pas
trop bien sûr voilà donc il a joué
maintenant d'un match 4 d'un match 4
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que il
revient aux h quatre contrôles et
toujours cette fameuse case egis mais
aussi maintenant la case que s est donc
un cavalier qui peut venir entre ces
deux faits en échec protégé par la dame
est aussi un deuxième cavalli qui peut
venir maintenant f6 faire un échec aussi
ceci dit on se dit mais attention le roi
maintenant il ya une case et 7 de fiona
donc on pourrait quand même prendre
oui alors admettons qu'ils comprennent
le cavalier donc d'un milkshake d'un
échec
cette deuxième promotion et simplement
nom original on t'apprend échec on
serait obligé de revenir gueddar entoure
et mat
donc je ne peux toujours pas prendre ce
tfc bourse était prévue liée
dommage car ça fait peur quand même oui
ça fait peur donc mais n'y étaient mal
autant c'était vraiment mon alors ça
c'est très important parce qu'à ce
moment là et lui deux minutes donc mais
moins que sa maman 20 minutes et il
était assez stressé était très stressé
c'est une position à double tranchant si
ce trompe hyper moyens comme dans la
partie donc ce pas mates
ouais il n'y a pas de gain immédiat donc
on va continuer à jouer précis que jouer
donc d'un bébé 2 donc dame b2 donc la
même idée qu'on donnait tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que on rajoute du contrôle
sur la case m6 puisque la dame contrôler
ici alors bon que j'avais vu n'y
verrions nous un peu donc il faut faire
attention qui avait lui aussi est échec
que je regarde surtout c'est parce qu'il
à fait normal et 5 avril c'est vrai donc
là s'il fait dirigé les trois succès
chez kroll évidemment maintenant on peut
venir en excellent puisqu'on à bruxelles
alors là il ya plusieurs coups il peut
jouer pour ses sets ça fait peur pour
ses sets mais là je vais je suis j'ai
des défenses comme sous 17 comme dans la
partie a ici mais on se demande qu'est
ce qui se passe après un coup comme h3c
lecavalier sec
je vous laisse
c'est à dire que le fou intercepte la
tour et maintenant la menace se reprend
bien sûr faux décès dans l'idée de fo 17
pour le spectateur faut expliquer parce
que c'est quand même très ciu qui sont
la revoir après c'est que si la tour
prend et bien le protège plus la casse
c'est un parce que maintenant 104 avant
en cas de cas de dame bien on pouvait
jouer pousser un latour restant c7 et
tout va bien mais là regardez pouf bas
du couloir c'est fini il faut donner le
faut on prend un fou fodé la dame
comprend la dame et ses matons cadet
andy avec notre gros jackpot c'est
compliqué à jouer puisqu'il ya plein de
petites subtilités qui sont pas faciles
à voir pas facile à boire parce que là
j'ai des coups comme cavalli prends ma
nuit il a joué n'est pas jouer ça n'est
pas john callas est inouï
madame b 2e 5,5 tout de suite oui ou non
il vaut ça que celle que sa voix pour
bloquer la diagonale de la gamme donc
ils bloquent le contrôle de la dame
noire sur m6 en jouant eux 5 et le
cavalier en plus ici qu'entre cette case
donc ça veut dire que et qu'est ce qui
se passe sur vous prend
sauf ou prend 1,5 et magnifique cavalier
il faut prendre simplement cavale et
prend maintenant sur d'impro qui là
aussi si longtemps et il ya quand même
cavalier psy ce chèque on les récupère
la qualité et une quinzaine en cavale et
prend et les leroy et le roi est très
faible moins jusque là est très faible
voilà que les pages jaunes mais à
égalité de matériel mais en fait
positionnement intel à poux est entre
nos mains et aura huit caisses qui joue
ça devient très pénible possible donc
que 5 fort coup quand même dangereux on
peut pas faire faux bond
on a il a coupé la lexus is et donc tu
as pris donc est donc là on se dit c'est
chou mais le problème c'est très
compliqué il reste 30 secondes
alors en fait il a joué cavalier 7
il semblerait que le coup cavaliers f6
bon j'ai pas trouvé de bien échec semble
forme sous prendre alors s'il faut
prendre
on se dit simplement content de me
baisser d'un cran menace maths en g7 et
d'un noeud bessette semble tenir ce que
j'avais regardé donc des six il ya des
cistes il faut pouvoir des six puisque
on contrôle la case de 7
d'ailleurs je sais 2007 quand même et
kallio cet avis du 7 au 11 est surprend
est et afyon prend le coup que j'ai peu
le couple d'apple à qui on prend parce
que là maintenant il faut prendre la
dame sinon on a
perdue puisque on a une qui ont passé un
trop fort
non non non mais justement parce que si
on prend il ya de l'armée chèques et les
maths et
imad puisqu'on le fou contrôlent la
quasi fluide donc c'est ma drogue par
exemple vous aussi ce donc là maintenant
et qu'il faut s'accrocher infosys et oui
les choisissent d'environ 2,5
voilà et les surnomme prendre cette le
roi est très mal aux hommes ont alors eu
cette scène vous et trois nuits de fou
des quatre autoroutes
pour ces six sans doute pour ces 6 e il
faut voir le match du couloir d'accès si
c'est bien a l'air fort parce que si on
achète adam g cet échec sur toronto en
fait je peux le comprendre on peut le
montrer
surtout ces six tours 8 tout reprendre 6
et sur d'un prend du matin g7
et oui voilà donc il semblerait que
kovalev ci sourit j'ai pas vu en fait
mais c'est difficile à voir c'est
quasiment impossible sur trois 30
secondes
il aurait pu voir intense il y aurait pu
le voir parce que là est le problème
c'est qu'il a presque trop de
possibilités puisqu'il peut faire ça il
peut faire l'autre donc oui mais lequel
choisir
donc il a fait cavalier cet échec qui
est intéressant aussi
oui
mais l'a pas vu la volonté 9 en europe
cette 3ème set ça c'est la partie
oui hélas il ay lille a pris 1,25 l'un
d'eux est pourquoi il prenait alors
l'idée c'est qu'en fait l'idée de ses
titres sur toute la j'ai par contre
faisait ça mais après je me suis dit
mais en fait si il fait call you say
they call et prend non pas pour l'idée
c'est de libérer la tour c'est qu'il
vient faire un hiver il veut venir faire
un échec ans et 7
c'est ça son idée donc cavalier prend
donc fou prend et il se dit j'ai gagné
puisque effectivement maintenant tour
ses sept
alors si tout est d'un prend on voit le
roi j'ai mis des monades si roger vite
la partie et d'ainsi roger vite qu'est
ce qu'il fait alors que j'avais vu quand
je finis sur ses parents devant donc la
partie qui relève six cavaliers m6 on
vous prend assez la partie en fin de
nuit c'est la partie e et d'un jeux
précités pas la partie la dame fera
hélas un coup complètement inattendu non
dans le b un échec
donc si l'on enlève la tour échec qui
joue torcéen je joue 2007 mais on se dit
c'est pas grave parce qu'en fait la tour
contrôle serre et rappelez vous il ya le
fou ce qu'on oublie toujours là et là en
fait il revient avec le fou non si ça
ils essaient d'y il avait calculé tout
il sait gagner maintenant parce qu'il
peut pas empêcher dame g7 ou dans les
sept matchs puisque si les noirs jouent
autour 7,2 je prends assez mal ou alors
jeté 17 c'est pareil je prends une
seimat
mais non mais non parce que tout 17 est
horrible oui parce que les verts ne
peuvent pas apprendre le fou donc sa
part le mat on peut pas prendre le fou
mais en plus cela on à laurent blanc qui
presque maths et encaisse qu'ils
pouvaient faire
c'est ça le truc ses cavaliers ont
quadrillé de cette croyance est un câble
et saigne de quel point ça ne marche pas
à cause de cette magnifique défense ont
été descellées set complètement
invisible je vais regarder oui c'est ça
j'ai regardé l'épreuve 5 encore d'osier
quelles épreuves cinq fonds transiteront
tour échec et donc orange et 8 et donc
la fout c'est un mineur et maintenant
vous c'est un ski est pas tout à fait
pareil voilà donc avec l'idée qu'elle
est si ces chèques vous prendre et d'un
proche est évidemment sept matches alors
que la vague et 6 la foule c'est un c au
nord de jouer d'am-dam voilà donc il
faut trouver les lave d'un v6 peut-être
d'un v6 attaque la tour et donc ce
qu'avait dit et si ces chèques je suis
dedans me prend je suis pas maître ya
pas mal sicilia m'attend en a six si si
je suis matin donc ça va tu as quoi bien
donc oui il faut regarder pousser en
fait poussé un oui ça a l'air bon et je
peux jouer aux dames français oui ben
fort en maths alors bien sûr je n'avais
pas tout calculé je me suis dit je peux
toujours prendre qu'ils ont franchi et
maintenant prend le cavalier et bombay
et le travail parce que là c'est pas
clair alors j'ai tout eu de foucque ont
presque voilà il ya deux fous d'autres
une tour les deux tours val la dame
donc ces tours est de fous contre la
gamme avec joie leur coin c'est plus
facile on peut plus attaquer le rend
facilement mais parce que le protège
donc ces endroits extrêmement jouable
oui j'étais sûr que ça allait quoi donc
là effectivement cavalière cet échec
mais bon ce qui va jouer sa paire donc
donc aller 25 terre et non le week end
si je vous fous ces ans après si je
faisais un mail avec la ballade de
compliquer voilà ce qu'il faut faire en
fait du coup c'est son fou c'est que
l'edf si c'est chez échec ip projet huit
cases et ses lacets voilà alors que ça
la réunion c'est là que c'est là que
l'erreur c'est l'acquéreur arrive
puisque donc on revoit cette magnifique
fin quand même superbe pour prendre et
forcé d'en prendre la smat le fou oui
d'abord échec
voilà bien sûr on revient pas avec la
tour parce que si on avec les retours je
les dom vayssette le tour à cette maman
non latins le seraient attaqués ah oui
pardon on va oui si la tour revient en
regardant sa blessure
dans ce cas là la dame relais en
vaisselle ou ce juste à temps on part le
matin donc l'idée c'est de revenir avec
le fou et dans ce cas là c'est la partie
le match est imparable puisque tour
cette marche pas je fais tu en prends à
senna tu es fou 17 je me fais pas
beaucoup mais non food et 7 je ne fais
pas en haut vous faut non il a joué 4 à
wil âge ou encore acheter hk thomas ses
8 est donc là c'est fini parce que je
change letterman show reprend 17
alors faut le voir quand même là ils
abandonnent et mais là donc qu'il faut
regarder quand même tout rang des cèdres
nous prendrons dame en fou à vue il le
roi est obligé de venir
et c'est fini avec le gros échange forcé
qui termine la partie
évidemment comme ça c'est terminé 2e
tour contre une c'est fini magnifique
quand même super parce que c'était tendu
on a vu que ça si là il a quand même
monter une attaque qui était extrêmement
qui semblait gagnante et mensualités
gagnant mais il s'est mis mal autant
pour trouver les coups gagnants
et oui c'est un roman de conclure avec
30 secondes à la pendule c'est toujours
ça c'était il ya le stress est une
question c'est la fatigue l'invasion de
stress fatigue s'ajoute et c'est là
c'est l'aspect sportif il faut jouer en
temps limité
oui en dollars aux banques
enfin l'on joue avec habib bien sûr
alors certes il y joue ça te fait un
début de tournoi extraordinaire puisque
2 sur 2 ouais de cette voie là oui enfin
ça à dormans et bon face à massifs
maxime et au moins dans mes hommages
surtout content parce que je perds le
chaque fois donc là c'était un gros
bonus mais bon tournoi et la maman
capital confiance capital confiance ils
vont former ça qui va se voir
je suis va dire non mais juste le titre
mais j'ai enfin c'est mon rêve c'est
d'avoir le titre
je n'ai pas eu il ya deux ans j'étais
tellement déçu
d'accord c'est vise le titre ne pourra
pas d'heure non je me mets pas plus de
pression mais je veux pas me dire que le
voilà je suis là c'est pour gagner mais
je veux dire papa de 2 me
pas de demi objectif roi non je suis
c'est quelque chose qui est dire qu on
n'est pas là pour s'annoncer pas là pour
s'amuser
oui avait su fermer toujours sont en
argent mat de grève sur des modèles tv
c'est pas la première fois
quelques temps il ya quelques temps déjà
merci beaucoup d'être venu avec nous
merci nous avoir suivi tous et puis je
vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine émission
dans ce tournoi dans ce championnat de
france cinquantaine 2015 qui est
passionnant déjà dès la deuxième ronde
et avait des champions très disponible
et qui nous font rêver tous deux
derrière nos écrans à suivre les parties
et avoir envoyé des magnifique
combinaison comme ça avait des
retournements de situation
extraordinaire mais avait des subtilités
et bien que nous on a de la peine à
trouver les qu'on trouve tout à fait
merveilleuse à voir chez nos grands
maîtres et notamment leurs maîtres
français des nations bon ben voilà
j'espère revenir et pourquoi pas et
surtout la lassitude gagne le titre
et oui oui voilà et voilà merci beaucoup
à bientôt à revoir